philippe pain président de l'union des
métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie dans les yvelines est en
ligne avec nous bonjour bonjour vous
cafetiers hôteliers restaurateurs et
exploitants d'établissements de nuit
vivent une situation catastrophique
actuellement avec toujours une fermeture
en ce milieu du mois de mai aujourd'hui
si on doit faire un état des lieux dans
les yvelines
est ce que les établissements vous
pensez peuvent survivre à cette crise
ils vont tout faire pour et je crois que
évidemment avec le le les aides du
gouvernement je pense que c'est ce qui
est c'est le but de rechercher mais
après il ya toujours des des situations
qui seront plus pénible que d'autres
nous en tant que fédération et on fait
tout pour que ça se passe le mieux
possible avec des pouvoirs publics
l'activité a été réduite à zéro depuis
le 17 mars
en ce qui concerne l'hôtellerie déjà
qu'on précise minutieuse oui en dehors
des hôtels qui ont été réquisitionnés
pour raisons pour loger des soignants
des aides soignants ou du personnel
médical tous les autres sont à l'hôtel
des hôtels dont ont quasiment tous
fermés
et effectivement c'est un chiffre
d'affaires perdu qui ne se rattrape pas
donc c'est même une semaine avant le
confinement c'était déjà très haut très
ralentie depuis début mars
si on imagine les perspectives de
reprise aucune date n'a encore été
annoncée
le gouvernement doit dévoiler encore des
des mesures d accompagnement pour le
secteur touristique au sens large
pas uniquement pour l'hôtellerie si on
se projette sur la suite vous imaginez
un retour à la normale possible cet été
cet été je sais pas parce que nous on
est on est dans l'île de france et son
nez plutôt une zone urbaine où le gros
de la clientèle de deux semaines sont
les les gens qui se déplacent pour
raisons professionnelles
donc les hôtels ouverts bien sûr
beaucoup d'hôtels ont rouvert le lundi
ce lundi alors c'est sûr qu'ils n'ont
pas adhéré un plein de révélations très
remplie mais ils ont ouvert pour
accueillir parce que les déplacements
les places professionnels sont autorisés
donc on peut espérer qu'un et en plus on
a été contacté par la fédération
française du bâtiment qui recherche
activement des chambres sur toute l'île
de france parce que les chantiers repris
et ça ça marche bien j'étais en lien
avec toute la direccte pour lister tous
les hôtels qui ont qui nous ont dit
rouvrir très immédiatement et donc sont
prêts à accepter ces personnes qui vont
intervenir sur les chantiers mais sur la
partie touristique
il ya aussi la son site us hommes sur la
ville de versailles par exemple tout
l'attrait internationale que peut
susciter le château de versailles
laval une des choses vont être assez
compliqué à remettre en othe aussi
absolument puisque le château est
toujours fermé et sera fermé à mon avis
et le parc pendant encore moins
jusqu'aux je sais pas je n'ai pas de
chiffres mais au moins jusqu'à fin
juillet
donc je vous fais route donc je ne sais
pas donc ça va évidemment sur le plan
touristique ça va être assez compliqué
après bon nous avons aussi des les
petits musées averse a aidé des centres
qui vont qu'ils vont ouvrir mais
évidemment c'est pas ça qui va qui va
relancer qui va relancer le tourisme
comme avant et un représentant du
secteur de l'hôtellerie dans le
département des yvelines à travers votre
syndicat est ce que vous avez eu le
sentiment est lorsque vous l'avez
aujourd'hui en tout cas d'être
accompagné par le gouvernement par
l'état par les assureurs aussi peut-être
votre syndicat était assez critiques sur
l'accompagnement des assureurs ou alors
sur l'état où ils clament en voilà la
confédération nos élus nationaux ont été
en permanence en relation avec le
ministère de bruno le maire daniel
spagnou a lâché moi qui ait un échange
vraiment très très bon qui est qui a été
qui a été fait donc l'être sur ce plan
là oui je pense que c'est ça s'est très
bien passé d'ailleurs on peut voir
toutes les aides et les avancées que
fiscale que nous avons obtenus qui sont
quand même non négligeable est assez
unique en europe je pense donc oui alors
sur le plan des assureurs par contre
l'annoncé et c'est le point noir
effectivement les assureurs ne jouent
pas le jeu et alors des négociations
sont en cours peut être qu'ils devraient
avoir un retour mais pour l'instant
c'est vrai que c'est très compliqué avec
eux et on et falla la profession est
vraiment très en colère sur le pont pour
conclure cet entretien vous parler de
ces hôtels qui sont en face de
réouverture depuis depuis le début de la
semaine pour certains avec une reprise
qui débute d'activité quelles sont les
normes sanitaires comment vous mettez en
place des normes sanitaires
un strict dans les établissements alors
pour l'hôtellerie donc il faut dire que
tout ce qui est restauration bien sûr
est supprimé puisque la leptine les
petits déjeuners seront uniquement servi
en chambre ou avec des plateaux qui
seront à disposition des clients dans le
dans le lobby les respectera bien sûr
les distanciation au niveau du check-in
aux vidéos des réceptions ira défier
dira d le personnel sera équipée de
vizir de masques de gants du gel
hydroalcoolique sera à disposition des
clients du personnel et y aura une
séparation bien sûr strict du traitement
du linge sale et du slash propre par
exemple les les gens qui quitteront leur
champ de noeuds pour les gens qui seront
libérés ne pourront pas être reloué
avant 24 48 heures on dit qu étrange hr1
c'est à dire qu'on pourra pas rentrer
dedans avant 24 48 heures donc pour les
autres petits hôtels c'est un problème
ensuite bien sûr il ya toute une
panoplie de 2-2-2 de consignes pour le
personnel des tâches qui sera qui seront
assez strictes oui on est sur place on a
mis ça en place en lien avec les agences
de santé
un coup est ce que ce sera répercutée il
y aura un coût forcément puisqu'on a un
hôtel ne pourra plus être rempli à 100%
et puisqu'il faut mettre des chambres en
jachère ce sera une activité à 50%
vraiment un minimum 50 ou 60%
mais les hôteliers estime que adapteront
leur personnel enfin leurs besoins
personnels en fonction de l'activité et
ça ça va durer un petit moment
malheureusement encore je sais pas pour
les coûts mais forcément il y aura des
coûts et
pour l'instant ce n'est pas on attend
les clients
merci philippe pas un président de
l'union des métiers des industries de
l'hôtellerie dans les yvelines
grâce à vous